[Music]
foreign
was conducting I was playing
and she goes
and everyone
and then the first time even talking
about it I get goosebumps because you're
awesome in this body of an orchestra
it's out of this world it's really it's
a moment of
it's so powerful
it's quite a thing to be in the real you
know Christmas symphonic obvious way
like I'm sorry I'm here I'm just the
Imposter
I learned so much about the position of
the first violin the concert master I
had no clue what a powerful position
that is the whole Orchestra looks at the
first somewhat like a translator between
the orchestra and the conductor
[Music]
so that was interesting for me for
Sharon because she has a power
Nina Haas I've done this film called the
audition where she plays a player who's
in the middle of a crisis and she's so
Sublime and so perfect in that so I
wanted somebody I mean hey she's one of
our best actors on the planet but B you
know that you would believe that she
could truly be the concert Master of the
greatest Orchestra on Earth
I play the piano and I started singing
when I was five years old I was always
surrounded by music but of course I
can't play mala's Symphony Number Five
so I worked a lot with my coach who
helped me so tremendously and at a
certain point I was able to actually
play it
when Nina came in she had much to say
about Sharon
everyone wants something personal from
tar but she's not that and Sharon is
maybe the only one who can easing her up
when she feels she can trust this person
in the last scene between the two
something has shifted and Sharon has to
protect the family but also her position
it's one of the most stunning scripts
I've read
it's so rich and has such a immense soul
to it
[Applause]
I find amazing what Todd did is that he
doesn't take you by the hand and tell
you what to sing throughout this film
you gotta make up your own mind
honestly I was blown away